and then as time goes on that we often
hear from many talented actors well I
don't want to do anything more for free
I'm willing now to tell the world that I
want to be paid what do you tell them I
don't think you can choose the
profession of acting worrying about
money I mean I understand you have to
pay bills and that of course needs to
happen but you can't choose that artform
because you want to be rich you want to
make money you have to choose it because
you love doing it and there's so many
examples of people that have flown
themselves to a certain city to meet you
know person with the director to
persuade them that they're right for
that part or somebody that has invested
and paid for their own production of
their own movie just to show you know
that they could play a different part
and what people think that they can play
and so the idea that you know you you
you can put it into you can invest it in
your career I think is important so
don't put a price tag on a project I
mean we always hear about people between
TV series doing free projects or short
films with friends just so that they're
active and it sounds like that's on TV
you get oh yeah absolutely I mean I
enough many friends that in between
television jobs and in between movies
are constantly on stage or constantly
volunteering to be at a friend's web
series for free and you know if you love
to act you love to act period
you